in the spirit of top gun day celebrating
the 35th anniversary of the film's
release guys
how about this we bring you top news at
four
oh my goodness
christian and christian and fuego
because we got music
i like it christian and fuego cazares
christian you look like nick jonas
he does he totally looks like he's
jonathan
but she looks better than kelly mcgillis
but wait guys there's more
oh wow oh my gosh look at tedla
i like it i like the shades too
when do you have time to be doing this i
don't actually i was going to say you're
always working so hard on the weather
this is crazy
this is our producer and everybody back
to scene
together together at two in the morning
because i mean she comes to work and
she's at it
yeah oh wow those are fun you guys can
wear these for the five
is that possible i don't know if that's
allowed love it
love it right condor we'll send it back
over to you
alright well living life to the fullest
one california team
is choosing to spread